sans faire attention que tout en dépend
c'est l'unité de mesure de toute chose
une convention admise par tous s'il
arrive quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins et
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes
mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue en direct
sur rt france pour 1h30 d'émission nous
décryptons comme chaque soir du lundi au
jeudi à l'essentiel de l'information
avec nos invités et nos reporters sur le
terrain une émission essentiellement
consacrée à la crise du couronna virus
en france et dans le monde
en france le ministère de la santé
annonce quatre cent soixante et onze
nouveaux décès ces dernières 24 heures
portant le bilan à plus de 4500 morts
depuis le début de l'épidémie il y
aurait eu au moins huit cents 84 décès
dans les maisons de retraite précise
jérôme salomon dans ce contexte de crise
sanitaire des voix s'élèvent médecins
policiers magistrats ou simples citoyens
allaient plainte contre le gouvernement
se multiplient
[Musique]
c'est désormais la moitié de l'humanité
qui se consignes en europe le ministre
français des finances bruno le maire
appelle les pays membres de la zone euro
à la solidarité a tandis que la
présidente de la commission européenne
s'excuse auprès de l'italie pour le
retard de la réaction de l'union
européenne
du côté de la russie vladimir poutine
déclare le mois d'avril chaud mais avec
salaire alors que la pandémie descend
lentement au sud à gagnant peu à peu
l'afrique
l'inquiétude grandit l économie mondiale
sévèrement touchés par l'épidémie de
coronavirus attrait l'europe c'est
l'économie américaine la première au
monde qui inquiète
industrie et services à l'arrêt millions
d'emplois menacés à les projections de
récession les plus alarmistes commencent
à circuler
elle cette crise présenté comme la pire
depuis 1945 un risque t'elle de
provoquer une nouvelle dépression est
c'est la question à laquelle
l'économiste jacques sapir tentera de
répondre dans sa chronique est qu à
21h15
[Musique]
en france on dénombre donc quatre cent
soixante et onze nouveaux décès ces
dernières 24 heures moins qu'hier avec
509 personnes décédées ce qui porte le
nombre total de victimes du coc vite 19
à 4500 trois personnes sur le territoire
à des chiffres donnés il ya quelques
minutes par le directeur général de la
santé elle jérôme salomon a également
annoncé la présence de 6399 personnes
dans les services de réanimation est la
france déplore 884 décès au sein des
ehpad à et c'est la première fois que le
directeur général de la santé indique
que le nombre de morts dans les
établissements pour personnes âgées à il
s'ajoute donc au nombre de personnes
décédées à l'hôpital et face à
l'épidémie coronavirus une nouvelle
stratégie fait son apparition en matière
de dépistage depuis quelques jours elle
est est en drive-in août est en plein
air se multiplient dans l'hexagone les
détails d'isabelle ferrières et de
cyrielle bois depuis lundi à mandelieu
la napoule communes des alpes-maritimes
un drive test a élu domicile sur un
parking en face d'un laboratoire
d'analysés médicales
l'objectif est simple éviter les
contacts notamment avec les soignants
pour limiter les risques de
contamination
triés sur le volet les patients testés
doivent répondre à certains critères
ils font partie du corps médical ou sont
en contact avec des personnes fragiles
ceux qui souffrent de pathologies à
risque sont également invités à se
présenter sur rendez vous les dossiers
sont constitués par téléphone et
transmis au laboratoire par les médecins
traitants dans ses drives seuls ceux qui
présentent des signes cliniques sont
testés sans même sortir de leur voiture
faut savoir qu'on a aussi des
prélèvements qui proviennent des maisons
de retraite des établissements de soins
actuellement les positifs sont plus dans
les maisons de retraite ou du souk où
les établissements de soins que sur la
patientèle direct ou là le corps médical
puisque honte est quand même pas mal des
gens qui sont dans le corps médical et
on verra dans un deuxième temps si on a
la possibilité de faire du dépistage à
plus large mesure en sachant que pour le
moment il faut plus de tests est une
organisation qui va avec mais surtout de
toute façon on n'a pas la possibilité de
prélever la population entière
une initiative saluée par les patients
même si certains médecins testés
s'interroge sur l'absence de sérologie
une mesure qui permettrait de révéler
une immunité ou non au corona virus j'ai
vu ça sur internet y est après midi donc
de tout de suite j'ai demandé à mon
calme a dit demandé au docteur elle va
vous faire une ordonnance qu'elle a
envoyée là tout à l'heure l'on voit là
c'est bien c'est une excellente
initiative
donc ça permet de protéger le personnel
soignant voilà parce qu'ils sont bien
protéger avec des masques avec des
charlottes avec des voilà donc avec des
tenues des tabliers et puis ça permet
aussi de mettre en évidence ces patients
qui sont atteints c'est important de les
mettre en évidence parce que ça permet
de les isoler de les confiner de
protéger leur entourage familial aussi
mais après c'est pas s'est pas élargie à
partir du moment où s'est pas élargie
c'est comme si on faisait rien en fin de
compte et c'est pas combinée à des tests
sérologiques aussi donc on sait pas si
on est immunisé ou pas est-ce que c'est
une immunisation récentes ou anciennes
voilà donc c'est un petit peu du
n'importe quoi à mon avis à moi qui
médecin qui est dans le domaine médical
mais après chaque médecin son propre
avis pris en charge par la sécurité
sociale
ces tests sont ensuite envoyés au
laboratoire il faut alors compter entre
3 et 4 heures d' analyse avant d'avoir
un résultat
actuellement ce centre effectué deux
séries de tests par jour ce qui permet
au patient d'être fixés dans les 24
heures une stratégie qui tend à se
développer progressivement sur
l'ensemble du territoire et le premier
ministre et loire philippe et le
ministre de la santé olivier ferrand ont
été auditionnés hier par 31 députés et
les présidents des huit commissions
permanentes de l'assemblée nationale la
mission d'information a pour but de
contrôler chaque semaine les mesures
prises par le gouvernement le premier
ministre et le ministre de la santé en
défendu la stratégie du gouvernement ils
ont notamment annoncé que le
déconfinement ne se ferait probablement
pas en une fois
partout et pour tout le monde et pour
parler de la pandémie en france et de sa
gestion
nous sommes avec jean christophe lagarde
président de l'udps et y député de la 5e
circonscription de seine saint denis
jean christophe lagarde merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france alors
pour commencer votre réaction aux
derniers chiffres annoncés en disait 471
décès ces dernières 24 heures plus de
4500 morts au total-- pour la première
fois un chiffre sur les personnes
décédées dans les ehpad qui s'élève à
884 quel est votre état d'esprit ce soir
je crois comme tous les français mais
grainage de ces de ces chiffres jour
après jour sont à la fois effrayant
meurtrissant et nous attendons de les
voir baisser alors ils ont beaucoup
augmenté au cours de ces dernières
semaines il continue à augmenter mais
moins vite ce qui semble montrer que
finalement comme l'expliquent le
gouvernement comme l'expliquent les
milieux médicaux celles et ceux les
soignants qui sont en train de essayer
de sauver le maximum de vies
c'est en restant chez nous qu'on
arrivera le mieux dans un premier temps
en tout cas à combattre le drame de
cette épidémie de cet ennemi des
épidémies pour la france mais pour
l'ensemble du groupe
ces chiffres il blesse il meurtrissent
ils font peur il fait peur et je crois
que la population française a de plus en
plus peur mais c'est aussi ce qui permet
que chacun puisse être raisonnable en
aidant nos soignants en restant chez soi
en dehors bien sûr de ceux qui sont
nécessaires pour faire fonctionner le
pays
nourrir la population garantir les
services publics les plus essentiels et
moi je veux rendre un hommage
particulier aux agents des collectivités
locales qui continue à travailler pour
que le pays ne s'effondre pas derrière
les soignants il ya aussi les policiers
et gendarmes les agents des
collectivités locales des caissières de
supermarché les gens qui mettent en
rayon qui continue à nous faire vivre et
si ces chiffres sont effrayants
ils doivent d'autant plus où donner une
énorme reconnaissance vis-à-vis de tous
ces français qui sont comme on dit en
deuxième demie mais en réalité font
vivre chacune et chacun de ceux qui sont
confinés
on va y revenir effectivement tout à
l'heure notamment dans votre
circonscription seine-saint-denis mais
avant
un mot sur la mission d'information hier
avec edouard philippe et olivier ferrand
vous y avait un participer selon vous
est-ce qu'ils ont répondu correctement
ou aux problématiques comme l'absence de
masques de médicaments encore la
question des tests aux problématiques
c'est une chose là aux questions oui
manifestement et moi j'ai été président
j'ai voulu créer j'ai été président
d'une commission d' enquête sur le h1n1
souvenez vous il ya une dizaine d'années
où justement nous avions préconisé qu'on
ait des stocks de masques considérable
on avait eu jusqu'à près d'un milliard
et demi de stocks de masques et puis en
une décision absurde folle dangereuse
dont il faudra un jour examiner les
raisons a décidé qu'on avait plus ou
moins masqué qu'on comptait sur la chine
pour en produire si un jour on avait un
problème
l'exact inverse de ce qu une commission
parlementaire que j'ai présidé avec jean
pierre door par ailleurs que l'on était
le rapporteur avait préconisé et donc on
se trouve aujourd'hui démunis de masse
c'est pas la peine de se payer de mots
jules jacques pharand si le mas tout le
monde donc la priorité a été donnée aux
soignants pour permettre que en plus de
la pénurie de masques on se retrouve pas
face à une pénurie de gens capables de
soigner les malades et notamment les
formes les plus graves
c'est ça ce qui est en train de se
passer alors le gouvernement répond avec
les moyens qu'il a puisque il n'a pas
inventé et les masques tout seul dans
son coin il essaye d'en acheter comme
tous les gouvernements du monde et j'ai
trouvé finalement que les réponses
étaient à la fois sincère frange est
vrai y compris et c'est sans doute
l'élément le plus important à comprendre
pour tout le monde quand le premier
ministre explique qu' il ya des choses
qu'on sait sur ce virus sur cette
pandémie et il est tout seul atout on ne
sait pas tout est effectivement qu avez
vous pensé d'ailleurs de cet aveu du
premier ministre je pense que c'est
sérieux
nous vivons sans doute à des moments les
plus graves que l'humanité a connu plus
de la moitié de la population plus monde
est confiné et il n'y a que quelques
gouvernements encore pour nier ou
essayer de minorer la gravité des choses
et donc que le premier 10 10
il ya des choses qu'on sait et sur celle
là on a quelques certitudes on peut agir
il ya des choses qu'on ignore encore et
ce n'est pas la peine de mentir aux gens
la crise est suffisamment bonne dame
nous sommes suffisamment
rappelons dans la difficulté pour ne pas
les employer un autre mot pourtant en
plus mentir et donc il dit voilà il ya
des choses dont on n'est pas encore
certain qu'on ne sait pas y compris
scientifiquement les scientifiques les
médecins il ya un mois il ya un mois et
demi
n'annoncez pas une crise d'une telle
gravité eux mêmes pensées faisait la
comparaison avec la grippe on a été un
certain nombre moi le premier à
reprendre cette comparaison
là c'est pas ça mais il ne savait pas à
l'époque
il ya des choses qu'on sait aujourd'hui
qu'on ne savait pas hier il ya des
choses qu'on ne sait pas aujourd'hui
qu'on sera demain il faut et le
confinement sert aussi à ça protéger les
soignants de parrot bonne dizaine au
total de l'hôpital mais laisser le temps
aux scientifiques aux chercheurs de nous
trouver des remèdes et des vaccins et ça
ça dépend de la responsabilité de
chacune et de chacun d'entre nous jean
christophe lagarde japon ça pour laisser
le temps à ceux qui savent de connaître
de comprendre de découvrir et aussi de
participer à une sauver jean-christophe
lagarde vous en parliez un la question
des masques objets de toutes les
convoitises
à ce sujet je voudrais vous faire
écouter renaud muselier c'était lundi
sur notre antenne le président de la
région paca a affirmé que des américains
avec acheter une commande française sur
le tarmac en chine
je vous propose de l'écouter puis on
écoute votre réaction les marques seront
fabriqués et en attente
aujourd'hui en chine des difficultés que
nous rencontrons c'est l'acheminement et
nous devions en avoir lâché les bombes
demain soir et dans ses tâches vide
énorme coup méfiants parce que nous
avons nous les pressions de france
en fait avec la fin des programmes
région commandes était de 60 millions de
marks pour nos régions respectives
sauf que ce matin lors de sur le tarmac
en chine une commande française a été
achetée par un américain un cache sur le
tarmac est l'avion qui devait hier en
france est partie directement en aux
états unis donc devant ces problèmes
large c'est en train de sécuriser la
la marchandise de façon à ce que il ça
passe par cvac et la filiale mondiale
dépendant de ces menaces gm qui est le
programmateur mondial mais façon à ce
que cette marchandise ne soit pas saisie
ou achetés par d'autres sur le tarmac et
donc je vous donnerai les dates précises
dans le courant de la semaine
alors cette lutte intransigeante menée
par les américains pour obtenir du
matériel de protection elle vous inspire
quoi est-ce que cela devrait être
contrôlés ou bien c'est la loi du marché
d'abord elle m'inspire deux choses nous
avons des présidents de région je pense
à renaud muselier je pensais pas mérité
crèche en salle jean rottner
bref qu'ils sont en train de faire le
maximum avec la puissance financière qui
est la leur la capacité de commandes
très large pour essayer d'aider à
approvisionner la france pendant que le
gouvernement essaye de faire la même
chose
c'est une très bonne chose et on doit
les en remercier et cuir derrière on a
un problème
en règle générale avec que les
américains d'abord parce que donald
trump comme boris johnson comme ce
dingue de golden arrow au brésil qui
continue à considérer qu'il ya rien qui
se passe rien on dit de nant tout ça
c'est pas grave n'y aura pas de problème
etc
et c'est sans doute aux etats-unis
comprises que le plus grand effondrement
sanitaire le plus grand nombre de morts
est le plus grand effondrement
économique
alors pour se rattraper avec l'agilité
et souvent le mélange entre la politique
et l'argent qui existe aux etats unis
ils sont effectivement avec des
pratiques indignes dans ces périodes de
crise d entrain d'essayer ici et là de
racheter voire trois fois quatre fois
plus cher c'est ce qui expliquait encore
ce matin renaud muselier en cash
là où nous on respecte des règles et il
faut les respecter
donc ça m'inspire comment des âges le
sel que c'est pas parce que les états
unis sont présidées par quelqu'un qui
n'a pas pris conscience de la gravité de
la situation
ils doivent maintenant essayer de se
rattraper avec le dollar sur le reste du
monde
mais ce qui compte pour ce qui nous
concerne c'est à la fois d'arriver à
sécuriser nos approvisionnements venant
de chine
faut pas que la chine soit incapable sa
pays communiste dirigiste très étatisée
donc il est capable de diriger les
commandes et de ne pas laisser ce genre
de pratiques se dérouler si le président
chinois le thread et que nous on soit
capable de multiplier les commandes
partout dans le monde et y compris par
la production française elle naîtra du
temps évidemment inventé en charge mais
commence à monter en charge que ce soit
des masques en papier comme ce qu'on
voit à l'image que vous diffusez que ce
soit des masques en tissu réutilisables
qui sont aussi s'ils respectent un
certain nombre de là une forme de
solution que deux pourrions produire en
france
alors pour terminer une dernière
question vous êtes député de sainte cène
de seine-saint-denis vous avez parlé de
l'importance du confinement tout à
l'heure vous votre département
et justement montré du doigt par
plusieurs élus pour le non-respect du
confinement la maire pcf d'aubervilliers
a elle même déclaré hier sur public
sénat avec qu'il y avait trop de monde
dehors elle a regretté que l'état est
annulé le couvre-feu instauré dans sa
ville quel est votre point de vue
justement sur cette situation dans dans
ce département de seine saint denis
écoutez moi comme tous les français
j'essaye de mastrad au confinement même
si belle fonction m'amène à me déplacer
de temps en temps et donc tout ce que je
vois ce débat aubervilliers qui est pas
si loin de 5 chez moi mais c'est ma
ville de drancy c'est les villes qui
sont autour de moi
et j'observe c'est le constat des
préfets du préfet c'est le constat de la
plupart des élus que contrairement à ce
qu'on raconte à la télé dans les milieux
bien pensants le confinement est
globalement bien respectée je ne suis
pas sûr qu'ils soient moins bien
respectés ailleurs je ne suis pas sûr
comme l'a dit le premier ministre hier
que tous ceux qui ont profité de leur
résidence secondaire pour partir à l'île
de ré ou ailleurs qui ont de ce fait
contribué à diffuser leur et le virus
dans la nation soient les mieux placés
pour fantasmer sur ce qui se passe ici
c'est vrai que c'est plus difficile pour
une famille qui vit à cinq ou sept
personnes dans un deux pièces de rester
confinés mais j'observe que les
policiers nationaux comme les policiers
bbc pour quand ils contrôlent des gens
qui sont dans leur rôle quand on regarde
ce qui se passe devant les magasins
y a des dès que de dizaines et de
dizaines de mètres ce qui pose la
question de la réouverture des marchés
d'ailleurs la réalité c'est que ces
gens-là ils ont le papier ils ont droit
d'être dehors et je vais vous dire je
suis passé dimanche un peu partout dans
ma circonscription il y avait presque
personne dehors
alors évidemment il ya toujours de 3
abrutis mais je suis pas sûr qu'ils
soient comme cette famille qui util
peuvent être dehors cela l'un d'entre
eux dans ma ville qui a été attrapé pour
la sixième fois dehors et maintenant en
délit et bien partir en prison
mais là
créée l'écrasante majorité de la
population un policier valises et 97 %
des gens qui sont contrôlées sont en
règle et ils sont pas si nombreux que ça
dehors par rapport à l'habitude merci à
ce que je veux dire à l'ensemble des
journalistes qui commande c'est fait on
a dit on va regarder la preuve que la
seine saint denis est un cilic
bref que les pauvres où les jeunes sont
ainsi rick c'est à dire qu'ils sont
abrutis qui préfère mourir c'est ça ce
qu'on est en train d'expliquer c'est que
les hôpitaux ont explosé eh bien je leur
demande de faire le boulot et d'aller
regarder les chiffres
pourquoi effectivement les hôpitaux de
cette année ont été rapidement complet
c'est parce qu'à moins b d'hôpitaux en
seine saint denis comme il ya moins de
policiers en scène ça me convient moins
d'enseignants seine-saint-denis il ya un
rapport parlementaire qui avait montré
tout ça donc si on est arrivé plus vite
au plafond c'est parce que le plafond
était plus bas message entendu immersive
merci jean christophe lagarde d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes président de l'udps et y
député de la 5e circonscription de
seine-saint-denis a mise en danger de la
vie d'autrui non assistance à personne
en danger ou encore homicide
involontaire à les plaintes se
multiplient depuis quelques jours à
l'encontre des autorités en cause la
gestion de la crise du coronavirus
associations syndicats ou simples
citoyens ils demandent des comptes à
l'exécutif explications en images
[Musique]
[Rires]
et pour parler des plaintes concernant
la gestion de la crise nous sommes avec
béatrice brugère les secrétaire général
du syndicat unité magistrats snm fo avec
son syndicat elle porte plainte contre x
pour mise en danger de la vie d'autrui
béatrice brugère merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur rt france alors pour bien
comprendre sur quelle fait votre
syndicat at il décidé de porter plainte
alors il faut comprendre que cette
action ait pas une action anodine a fait
pour tirer la sonnette d'alarmé auprès
de notre ministère et surtout cette
action judicaire fit d'abord l'échec du
dialogue social constructif que nous
avons a tenté depuis plus de quinze
jours ça vous a pas échappé que peu de
gens et y compris les journalistes
parlent des magistrats et même si vous
voulez l'activité judicaire aujourd'hui
est relativement réduite elle continue
et on encore des magistrats des
greffiers des personnels qui travaillent
entrer dans ciel dans l'écrit villo
qu'est ce que vous dénoncez qu'est-ce
que vous déversez depuis quinze jours
notamment milliards depuis
il voulait à quinze jours depuis le
début de la gestion de la crise qui a
été très très difficile à mettre en
place
on a eu des injonctions contradictoires
très fort de rester confinés les deux
quand même continuer à travailler
une forme tout à fait normal parce que
les affaires que david publics régaliens
mais on a aussi un peu de tout des
petits mais dès le départ je voulais la
protection des personnels en fait notre
ministre nous a déclaré que les mac
était totalement inutile que les pestes
ça ferait pour la fin du confinement et
que simplement les gestes barrière
suffirait à protéger justement tout ce
personnel des magistrats qui continue à
travailler dans les juridictions
or on a constaté très vite qui manquait
du gel que les gestes barrière n'était
pas suffisant que la multiplication des
d'extraction judicaire et du personnel
policier etc ne permettait pas partout
de respecter ces gestes barrières
béatrice pour autant effectivement il ya
eu des mesures de réorganisation de
prise par le
ministère de la justice pense notamment
la simplification des procédures à la
tenue d'audiences en visioconférence par
exemple les audiences à huis clos
malgré ces mesures qui ont été prises
ça vous n'êtes pas satisfaites et vous
portez plainte pour en fait c'est le
dire qu'ils ont quand même du temps à
être pris qu'ils voulaient nous sommes
totalement insuffisante parce que
aujourd'hui on le voit aussi parce qu'il
ya déjà une inscription
tout le monde commence par à comprendre
que le port du masque est important il
n'est pas du tout inutile et nous on
demande en urgence des têtes pour que
toutes les personnes qui viennent
travailler soit détectée pour pas
contaminer les autres et vous voulez on
demande que les personnels qui sont
encore là et des masques et qu'on puisse
avoir du gel par tous donc les chiffres
nous donnent raison parc de semaine en
semaine
nous avons de plus en plus de contaminer
parmi le personnel judiciaire et nous
sommes pas du tout entendu sur cette
demande qui nous semble relativement
simple de tester les gens
systématiquement y compris dans les
tensions d'ailleurs c'est là exactement
la même chose et donc ma démarche est
pas aidé du tout une démarche politique
elle est une démarche de responsabilité
aujourd'hui on n'a plus le temps
d'attendre
il faut absolument que ceux qui sont aux
commandes de l'administration prennent
conscience que ils ont une
responsabilité en tant qu'employeur de
ne pas mettre en danger leur personnel
alors on rit tout pas ou à bon prix
alors votre organisation syndicale est
minoritaire chez les magistrats
est ce qu'on peut attendre une réaction
rapide malgré tout à ce que votre
procédure a une chance d'aboutir selon
vous m'expliquez on verra de toute
attaque on voit déjà une inflexion
depuis deux trois jours on voit
davantage de mac arrivé alors qu'on nous
avait dit qu'on en aurait jamais on voit
du gel arrive et outils dans les
juridictions donc qu'un cours fin on est
déjà extrêmement content si vous voulez
de cette nouvelle réorientation
évidemment que c'est pas suffisant je
vous parle même pas des territoires
ultramarins qui sont extrêmement délits
et qui n'ont pas grand chose donc si
vous voulez c'est pas que symbolique à
on verra ce que ça donne
évidemment mais cette action est là
aussi pour intérêt de pointer les
détaillants à ne pas en produire dans
l'avenir on aura de crise c'est évident
et il faut absolument prendre conscience
qu'une gestion de crise ne peut pas se
faire au doigt mouillé et qu'il faut
rien entendre les acteurs du terrain
alors il ya une nouvelle plainte qui a
été également déposée contre messieurs
castaner nunez et philippe pour mise en
danger délibérée de la vie d'autrui elle
a été déposé par le syndicat policier
vigie est ce qu'il ne fallait pas
attendre au moins la fin de l'épidémie
pour enclencher des procédures
judiciaires
alors d'abord nous on n'a pas pu déposer
plainte contre contre quelqu'un de
perdre on a on n'est pas du tout dans
cette logique là on cherche pas à avoir
des fonctions faire tomber quelqu'un ce
n'est pas du tout notre démarche sont
les très constructif moi je crois qu'au
contraire c'est maintenant qu'il faut
agir parce qu'à la fin du confinement on
comptera peut-être les morts ou les gens
qui ont été en grande difficulté or
c'est aujourd'hui qu'il faut prendre les
mesures le discours de l'union nationale
n'a pas de temps
si on n'écoute pas les acteurs du
terrain qui guide la question là il ya
une vraie possibilité de mise en danger
et on demande à notre administration de
nous protéger il ne faut pas oublier
qu'au contraire ce temps est extrêmement
précieux on n'est pas là pour faire le
bilan après de voir qu'il n'a pas été
fait ou pas bien face à l'idée c'est que
tout de suite une prise de conscience
que nous avons besoin de davantage de
protections et surtout ils composent
liés que nous sommes amis père régaliens
la justice est un pilier comme les
hôpitaux comme l'armée comme la police
il faut absolument protéger nos agents
parce que nous avons une obligation
d'assurer un service public
merci de manche voilà si demain tout
l'équipement au travail sont contaminés
on aura plus personne
merci beaucoup béatrice brugère d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes secrétaire général du syndicat
unité magistrats snm
fo et dans quelques instants nous
partirons en italie confiné au moins
jusqu'à pâques puis direction les pays
bas où les habitants conserver une forme
de liberté même s'ils sont invités à
rester chez eux
puis nous reviendrons sur la situation
au sénégal qui poursuit le traitement à
la chloroquine après des résultats
encourageants rester avec nous sur ft
france
[Musique]
si vous fermez les bois ans nous
empêcher les gens de vendre et donc vous
les condamnez à une poursuite de la
baisse qui veut dire qu'on va être dans
une récession monumentale mais est ce
qu'on peut imaginer que les épargnants
puisse être inquiétés et ont des raisons
d'être inquiets à cause de cette fille
oui bien sûr que vous avez aujourd'hui
un risque majeur qu'on ne vous rend pas
d'autres cas c'est une évidence
à aucun moment dans l'histoire récente
vous n'avez eu des pays à l'arrêt jamais
à l'échelle européenne quelles peuvent
être ses réponses excusez moi il n'y a
pas d'europe
c'est bien d'ailleurs une des grandes
leçons de ce coin on a un virus c'est
que l'europe est si elle a un jour
existé est morte
[Musique]
nous allons évoquer ici des sujets
stratégiques pour notre pays et sur ces
dossiers sensibles
je vais partager avec vous une
interprétation en france une quinzaine
de zones ont été sélectionnés dans les
années 90 par des militants juillet la
première erreur de notes administration
a été de croire que les terroristes
étaient des loups solitaires alors
qu'ils étaient là résultant de 15 ans de
travail de fond fait par les élèves et
on clair ils ont prêché la guerre sainte
et le problème c'est qu'on les a trop
longtemps laissé il ya eu un espèce de
déni de réalité et il a fallu le drame
du bataclan pour qu'il y ait enfin une
reconnaissance générale de la situation
dans notre pays
la ministre de la justice par un
belloubet annonce la sortie en 2020 de
40 3 du à 10 140 avant fin 2022 sur les
531 incarcéré aujourd'hui
qui peut croire que la majeure partie de
ces individus mus par la haine de la
france est désormais libre ne sont pas
un défi pour la sécurité nationale
[Musique]
le zéro derma pigmentosum c'est une
hypersensibilité aux rayons ultraviolets
en fait c'est une maladie génétique qui
est transmise par les deux parents dont
les deux parents sont porteurs sains de
la maladie ce qui transmed qui
transmettent en fait alors à leurs
enfants des enfants ne peuvent pas
s'exposer au soleil
acial comment on pourrait résumer une
journée type de votre vie ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est que il faut pas qu'ils
aient un millimètre de pau qui soit
exposé apporte ses gants ses vêtements
on leur met leur masque avec la visière
qui leur permet de regarder à
l'extérieur
une fois qu'ils y sont ma fille je veux
pas qu'elle ait une vie où elle reste
tout le temps à la maison c'est pas une
vie tu auras la vie comme tout le monde
et ça je le ferai tout pour que ça soit
le cas
les ogm c'est la cerise sur le gâteau de
la culture intensive et chimiques et le
nombre de techniques pour faire des ogm
a explosé pendant les 15 dernières
années les ogm c'est un outil c'est tout
ce qu'il a il ne pourra rien faire
contre la faim dans le monde
puisqu'en fait la faim dans le monde est
une question politique alors ça c'est
les ogm
il ya également le glyphosate alors le
niveau 7 à usage agricole
on pourrait s'en passer il ya des façons
de produire qui peut se passer de tout
terminer il ya des gens qui ont un
intérêt à ce que ces molécules hla
soient pulvérisés sur les champs
ce que ça rapporte énormément d'argent
peut-être que ça arrange l'industrie on
parle que du glyphosate parce qu'il ya
beaucoup d'autres herbicides
ils sont en jeu et le glyphosate et
d'une molécule qui est tombé dans le
domaine public
elle n'a plus de problème dans tout le
monde peut en produire il ya d'autres
herbicides qui sont en train d'arriver
il ya beaucoup de choses qui sont de
l'ordre de l'économie d'accord on nous
impose ces choses là
non pas parce qu'il ya un intérêt social
parce qu'un intérêt économique
[Musique]
de l'année
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez en direct sur rt france il est
20h30 heure française une émission
largement consacrée à la crise du
coronavirus dans le monde la patronne de
l'union européenne présente ses excuses
à l'italie
dans une tribune parue aujourd'hui dans
la presse italienne ursula von der leyen
a tenu à exprimer ses regrets pour le
retard de réaction de l'union européenne
face à la pandémie de koffi diby koffi
19 vécue par l'italie ursula von der
leyen a présenté ses excuses avant de
préciser je cite aujourd'hui l'europe se
mobilise aux côtés de l'italie mais cela
n'a pas toujours été le cas à elle a
également annoncé que l'union allait
allouer 100 milliards d'euros aux pays
les plus durement touchés en commençant
par l'italie et la situation en italie
toujours aussi préoccupante on le
rappelle c'est le pays le plus touché en
europe
le bilan est lourd 13 1915 morts dont
760 en 24 heures et plus de 115 1242
contaminées selon une ong de défense des
droits des prisonniers un premier détenu
est mort le ministère de la justice a
annoncé que tous les prisonniers le
personnel des centres de détention de la
région de naples seraient testées au
début de la semaine prochaine et pour
parler de l'europe mais surtout de
l'italie nous sommes avec antonella bord
à lévis et éditorialiste à la stampa
antonella bord à lévis merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france alors
quelle a été la réaction
en italie après les excuses de l'union
européenne vous savez que déjà avait dit
avec beaucoup de rhétorique
non ici moto italienne
nous les italiennes ou connaissant très
bien la rhétorique et voilà je pense que
bon les excuses elles sont toujours bien
venues
mais ça ne change rien ça changera la
question seulement quand les européens
comprennent pas qu'il faut faire les
airs au bond
parce que sinon vraiment l'europe à mon
avis va cesser solide et une [ __ ] est
surtout sol
justement vous vous l'évoquiez à
l'instant les pays du sud de l'union
européenne c'est à dire l'espagne
l'italie et la france ont réclamé une
cette mutualisation de la dette à ce que
vous appelez les corona bon et les pays
du nord l'allemagne les pays bas eux
rejettent cette option est ce qu'on va
être face à de nouvelles tensions au
sein de l'europe selon vous a bien sûr
mais je pense aussi et c'est dommage
mais j'ai je vais dit à la télé vraiment
à la télé italienne
il y a des mois je vais demander
pourquoi on ne prendrait pas de mesures
de précaution pour l'épidémie que vous
savez à la chine est apparue au début de
mois déjà maintenant la même situation
je pense soit au nord de l'europe
c'est à dire que c'est pays il ne
comprend pas qu'ils vont se trouver
exactement dans notre situation ça va
changer
vraiment je pense leur avis sur les
couronnes aborde alors pour revenir à la
situation dans votre pays l'italie
les nombre de nouvelles hospitalisations
et d'admission en soins intensifs
augmente moins vite
on l'a vu à peine plus d'un pour cent de
hausse mardi soir pour ces deux
indicateurs et l'accroissement du nombre
de décès est aussi moins rapide il se
stabilise
sous les 8% depuis trois jours c'est une
lueur d'espoir pour les italiens voilà
la question c'est exactement ça je pense
que la peur cet abus panique ces mesures
pour ses protégés la paire va nous
protéger parce que si nous avons père
nous faisons c'est qu'on appelle la
distance sociale c'est à dire que nous
restons à la maison et nous faisons pas
des choses qui vont nous mettre en péril
alors maintenant à l'italie on a
vraiment un gros problème parce qu'il ya
beaucoup de gens qui pensent que le
ralentissement de l'épidémie qui s'est
vraiment très paix il faut les dire
voilà nous avons eu presque 700 morts ça
veut dire que il y à l'épidémie vous
savez à milan dans cette période
d'épidémie
on a eu les 76 % en plus des morts par
respect à les chiffres de l'année
dernière dans la même période
alors les risques ici j'espère que ça ça
va terminer vite mais les risques c'est
que on n'éprouve plus au sérieux le
règle parce que heureusement nous sommes
un pays démocratique et alors on ne paie
pas il posait aux gens de rester à la
maison
mais il faut faire compte sur la
responsabilité de chacun et
malheureusement par exemple il faut les
dire je vous le dis parce que je pense
que en france
il faut savoir ce que c'est parce en
italie parce que malheureusement le son
ep avant à vous pour ces queues qui
concerne la situation
alors justement il se dit que de naples
à palerme de nombreuses italien exclut
commences ta protesté de leur abandon
est ce que c'est le cas est ce qu'il ya
un véritable risque de pillage dans la
région comment les autorités gèrent la
situation
voilà en question parce que vous savez
que l'italie
a toujours de face c'est-à-dire la face
européenne c'est-à-dire lé nord et les
centres et la phase qui si bons qu'ils
ne marchent pas tellement tellement vite
tellement bien vers le futur qui sait le
sud est aussi que malheureusement nous
avons beaucoup de ce que nous appelons
lavoro miro c'est à dire les gens qui
travaillent sans payer les taxes et sans
avoir un encadrement ce sens à voir
comment dit-on pour bourg quand vous
vous êtes payés régulièrement ils ne
sont pas employés
on les paye cash alors ces gens là et
ils ont bu ou totalement partie tous et
qu'il pouvait gagner parce qu' ils sont
des gens qui font des boulots par
exemple pour les parkings qu'ils vendent
des choses au marché ou bien qu'ils font
de petits travaux à la maison et
personne ne l'appelle plus de les payer
plus et voilà nous avons beaucoup
beaucoup de gens qui demandent des de
l'argent pour marché pour acheter les
choses pour manger et les vrais péril
pour nous c'est que cette situation soit
géré et non par les gouvernements qui
scellera un dogue allemand
mais malheureusement pour la mafia qui
va profiter des ca pour s'est réaffirmé
comme une organisation qui s'occupe des
gens et ça c'est serré vraiment le
désastre alors pour conclure il nous
reste très peu de temps mais le
déconfinement doit être dans toutes les
têtes à vous l'évoquiez tout râleurs
quelle stratégie selon vous apprendre le
gouvernement italien âgé parce que bon
on espère que ça va ralentir
c'est à dire qui on va rejoindre les
piques et alors je pense que les
prochains décret du gouvernement c'est à
dire à la boîte et des d'avril après
pâques sert à quelque chose qui va
réouvrir très lentement avec tous les
protections et surtout chez nous on se
parle de faire une différence entre les
gens qui vont revenir à leur boulot à
travers les rage
c'est à dire que les gens ils vont
retourner au boulot et les
cinquantenaires et après ils vont rester
à la maison peut-être avec les marques
woking je pense que ça ça va être parce
que pour ça mais pas de tous les
théâtres les fêtes les cinémas bow non
seulement les usines
parce que pour nous vous savez les
ouzzine sont très importants merci
beaucoup on tenait la bo à lévis d'avoir
répondu à nos questions et je rappelle
que vous êtes éditorialise merci
beaucoup et rappelle que vous êtes
éditorialiste à la stampa
et puis l'espagne deuxième pays le plus
endeuillé si la barre symbolique des dix
mille morts dépassé dans le pays et 950
nouveaux décès en moins de 24 heures les
malades pris en charge à l'hôpital sont
confinés et se retrouve parfois isolées
jusqu'à leur mort difficile pour eux et
pour leurs proches privé du dernier au
revoir quand un mot claire et grégoire
ou cette deuxième foyer européen de la
pandémie due qu'aux vide 19
l'espagne voit sa situation se
détériorait jour après jour si l'armée
est déployée dans les rues pour faire
respecter les mesures en vigueur
elle ne peut rien faire face à la
solitude des personnes infectées
dès qu'un malade monte dans une
ambulance
il lui est désormais interdit d'avoir
tout contact avec ses proches
c'est vraiment très difficile en ce
moment je n'ai pas vu ma mère depuis
quatre ans et voilà qu'on doit lui dire
adieu
ils assez triste
et la voilà être malade et isolés dans
les derniers moments de sa vie
c'est une triste réalité qui plane
actuellement sur l'espagne pour la
famille et les proches
impossible de dire au revoir impossible
également d'organiser des funérailles
publiques seulement trois personnes
peuvent être présentes à l'enterrement
et ce quelle que soit la cause du décès
ils ont tout fait pour nous toute leur
vie ma grand-mère a consacré 86 ans à sa
famille à ses petits j'entends et
maintenant des gens meurent sans intérêt
à dieu sans que quelqu'un la team de la
main cette idée m'attriste de nombreux
lieux sont quant à eux de transformer en
orgue temporaire pour entreposer les
corps des défunts dans la tente de la
crémation ou de l'enterrement
comme ici à la patinoire de madrid
devoir affronter un deuil seule une
véritable épreuve à surmonter le prix
difficile à quiconque à la partager la
douleur des proches compagnons sommes
désolés nous ne pouvons pas aller à
l'hôpital pour être à l'achat
nous sommes obligés de vivre une perte
de manière inhabituelle
il est à la solitude face à la
saturation des hôpitaux le personnel
médical tente de s'adapter pour faire
face à l'afflux toujours aussi important
de patients à de nombreux patients qui
il y à quelques temps avant le virus
aurait été admis dans une unité de soins
intensifs ne peuvent plus être soignées
dans ces unités et sont laissés progrès
net ou plutôt ne peuvent pas s'en sortir
et puis nous essayons d'autres solutions
moins conformistes comme l'adaptation de
masques de plongée sur les appareils
respiratoires
mais cela nécessite néanmoins un
dispositif ventilation dont nous n'avons
pas encore assez d'unités
le pic de l'épidémie n'est toujours pas
été atteints et l'espagne comptent déjà
des milliers de morts et plus de cent
mille cas répertoriés seule bonne
nouvelle
plus de 22 mille personnes sont
considérés comme guéris
en russie le gouvernement annonce un
mois d'avril chaud mais avec maintien de
salaire c'est l'une des différentes
mesures prises par moscou pour freiner
la propagation du virus
vladimir poutine envisage également de
déclarer l'état d'urgence nationale il
s'est exprimé cet après midi retour sur
cette prise de parole avec notre
correspondant à moscou antoine gayraud
bien le président russe a tenu à faire
le point à l'issue de la semaine chaumet
décrété mercredi dernier il a souligné
que la situation sur le front sanitaire
était difficile compliqué mais comme il
l'a fait remarquer en relevant aussi ce
qui se passe dans les autres pays c'est
en limitant au maximum les interactions
entre les gens que l'on parvient à
enrayer la propagation du colis 19 la
meilleure poutine a donc décidé
d'étendre la période chômée avec matière
de salaire jusqu'à la fin du mois
d'avril d'écouté pour prendre ses
décisions et il faut bien comprendre que
ce risque se maintient et comme le
disent les spécialistes en virologie le
pic de l'épidémie n'est pas encore passé
notamment dans notre pays
pour cette raison j'ai pris la décision
de poursuivre cette semaine de congé
jusqu'à la fin du mois d'avril c'est à
dire jusqu'au 30 avril
avec le maintien des salaires
le président russe a fait savoir que la
situation sanitaire n'était pas homogène
sur tout le territoire
si les grandes villes comme moscou en
premier lieu était davantage touché les
mesures de confinement sont donc amenés
à 6 prolonger voire se durcir al'inverse
il existe des régions de russie à
l'intensité bien plus faibles où la
situation peut être différente
les autorités locales sont donc priés de
s'adapter d'adapter sur le terrain des
mesures de confinement en fonction de
l'évolution de cette crise sanitaire
enfin vladimir poutine en a appelé à la
responsabilité et la solidarité de ses
concitoyens des valeurs indispensable à
ses yeux pour pouvoir surmonter cette
épreuve et toujours avec ce double
objectif préserver la sécurité et la
santé de la population tout en essayant
de maintenir l'emploi est certaine
stabilité économique à la situation d'un
freak maintenant plus précisément au
sénégal où la population est sévèrement
touchée par l'épidémie de coronavirus
plus de 195 cas répertoriés 1
ils essaient enregistré celui de
l'ancien président de l'olympique de
marseille pape diouf
depuis une semaine un couvre-feu a été
instauré une vaste campagne de
désinfection se déroule tous les soirs
dans les rues de dakar récit de clément
hospital avec les images de louis danga
la nuit est tombée sur les rues de dakar
alors que la population est appelée à
rentrer chez elle à 20 heures pour le
couvre-feu une brigade vêtus de
combinaisons blanches arpente les
quartiers de la capitale pulvérisateurs
en main pour faire la chasse aux virus
ça me rassure employés
je pense qu'il faudrait que ça se répète
et puis souvent parce que bon on
comprend ces des quartiers un peu ce
peuple et donc il faudrait à mon vin que
j'en passe par là pour informer de plus
en plus sensibilisés je pensais les gens
peuvent dans la commune d'ailleurs tout
le monde à peu en vérité cette
adversaire invisible mais redoute à dans
le sud de la capitale
les quartiers les plus aisés font
également l'objet d'une grande opération
de désinfection depuis une semaine
rue école au lieu de culte tout l'espace
public et traiter systématiquement dakar
est en effet l'une des capitales
africaines les plus touchés par le crown
un virus parce que le virus
il n'y a pas de médicaments il n'y a pas
d'adversaire mais ne réussit pas à la
table des inspecteurs haut niveau
conduite des appareils de pointe
le single est l'un des pays d'afrique de
l'ouest le plus touché par l'épidémie
le confinement général n'y a cependant
pas encore été décidé le président macky
sall a adopté des mesures strictes pour
endiguer la propagation du virus entre
autres la fermeture des frontières
aériennes et terrestres ainsi que celles
des écoles également mis en place
la limitation des transports
interurbains et l'interdiction des
rassemblements publics
le pays s'apprête donc à fêter ce samedi
le soixantième anniversaire de son
indépendance sans célébration et pour
parler de la gestion de la crise au
sénégal nous sommes avec amadou bah il
est chercheur associé au groupe afrique
de l'institut prospective et sécurité en
europe
lips mamadou bah merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur rt france alors le
traitement par chloroquine se poursuit
au sénégal après visiblement des
résultats encourageants en france on le
sait c'est un sujet toujours controversé
un haut responsable de la lutte contre
la maladie indique que les malades
guérissent plus vite c'est un avis
partagé au sénégal il ya des études
c'est un vrai espoir comment cela se
passe effectivement c'est un avis très
partagé par la population
ce que depuis le commencement de la
famille
le professeur moussa seydi qui le chef
du département d'infectiologie de
l'hôpital fann a suivi les travaux du
professeur raoul de marseille c'est
qu'il ya eu un impact vraiment
significatif sur le traitement de cette
maladie
aujourd'hui nous arrivons à guérir avec
7,5 millions puis 2 194 malade est
aujourd'hui 135
ils sont sous traitement et la maladie
est en cours au je peux dire de trouver
une solution médicale au niveau de
l'hôpital de rome alors le président
macky sall ne sera plus tenu de passer
par l'assemblée nationale pour légiférer
sur des questions d'ordre économique
budgétaire financière juridique
sanitaire sécuritaire pendant trois mois
une décision pour éviter de réunir à
l'assemblée nationale et protéger ses
membres
est ce que cela traduit une vraie prise
de conscience de la situation
effectivement c'est une vraie prise de
conscience de l'homme de la situation
parce que le 24 mars le président de la
république
ap une décision majeure de détendre les
mesures prises à medupi ne contrôle avec
le couvre-feu est intégrée par les
grades d'urgence et sur ce il a saisi
l'assemblée nationale directement pour
voter une loi de réhabilitation essai de
loi propose au président de la
république de pouvoir gouverner par
ordonnances pendant trois mois ce qui
fait qu'aujourd'hui nous pouvons passer
sur des décisions qu'ils vont vraiment à
l'encontre de la population mais pour
les protéger ne peut passer à ces
mesures d'urgence jusqu'à prendre des
décisions majeures comme la création
d'un fonds d'urgence de 1000 milliards
de francs cfa environ ce qu'on peut dire
un euro contre 1 et 2 milliards d'aud
nous et les non seulement le personnel
médical à lutter contre ce fléau comme
ce bus et les élus sur le poids du
matériel et des matériaux
en plus de ça des médicaments et ce plan
aussi aider aussi à une bonne partie
pour aider les entreprises qui sont
et à cette situation on peut dire
qu'aujourd'hui beaucoup beaucoup de
secteurs de l'économie sénégalaise est
paralysée par cette pandémie
on ne peut pas y aller ni en tout cas
ils sont choqués c'est d'être là jouent
amadou bah il ya normand l'opposition
qui craint au contraire de donner une
trop grande liberté d'action au
président le texte pourrait justifier
des législations qui n'aurait rien à
voir avec l'épidémie qu'est ce que vous
en pensez
l'opposition sénégalaise est dans son
rôle on ne peut pas l'empêcher de donner
son avis et de dire aussi s'ils sont
d'accord ou pas parce que le rôle de
l'opposition c'est de contrôler le
pouvoir exécutif outre je pense que l'on
doit les écouter et prendre conscience
qu'ils sont en train de berck
mais à cette heure où la situation est
grave et très grave il faut des mesures
urgentes
nous devons être dans l'union et ses
lions que fait la force
nous devons tous être ensemble derrière
le président de la république
où trouver les solutions vous trouvez
des moins à endiguer ce virus est gagnée
cette guerre sanitaire qu'on a entrepris
avec tous les toutes les organisations
de la société civile des chefs religieux
des acteurs de développement
tout ce qui sort de venir ensemble
d'élire le président de la république
pour trouver une solution rapide l
équateur pour barrer plus haut niveau
des pays
alors on voit ces images de désinfection
des rues de dakar est-ce que c'est
efficace en tout cas ça n'a pas été
encore prouvé me semble-t-il où c'est de
la communication
je ne sais pas si c'est efficace que non
mais nous n'avons mais nous avons vu que
ça a été pratiquée à wayne dans la ville
où l'épicentre
ils veulent et s'arrêter au niveau de
lâcher ça a été pratiqué aussi en corée
du sud
pourquoi pas le sénégal ne doit pas
l'adopter pour trouver des solutions et
s'est désinfecté poussé luxe lui ces
places publiques en fait de tuer les zus
quel est l'état de la population quel
est l'état d'esprit de la population
sénégalaise on a vu un le décès de pat
pape diouf qui a marqué beaucoup de
monde également en français ce qui la
constitue à un vrai choc
ce n'était pas n'importe qui c'était une
très grande personnalité du pays c'était
money money money masse personnalités du
monde du foot de la culture et d'art
aujourd'hui avec son décès à cause de ce
virus qui l'a emporté on peut dire que
ça ait un impact vraiment important sur
la population sénégalaise qui dès
maintenant a pris conscience de
l'urgence de respecter les consignes
décrété par le gouvernement de rester
dans les maisons et de suivre tout ce
que le président décide
colton il se faisait par exemple par
exemple le couvre-feu mise en place par
le gouvernement il est bien respectée
aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui nous tandis que le coucou
forte et respectée
même s'il ya des récalcitrants on peut
dire que ça a été respectée par une
bonne partie de l'étendue des crachats
que ça soit à dakar que ça soit un
pouvoir qui est le deuxième ville la
plus touchée passent et plus on peut
dire que au niveau de toutes les régions
du sénégal
ça a été respectée merci beaucoup à
manouba d'avoir répondu à nos questions
je rappelle que vous êtes chercheur
associé au groupe afrique de l'institut
prospective et sécurité en europe
face à l'augmentation des cas de
contamination certains pays touchés se
retrouvent dépassés ils ont parfois ils
sont parfois dans l'obligation de mettre
en place rapidement des hôpitaux de
fortune voir des morgues de substitution
regarder
[Musique]
avant
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on
non
pour
[Musique]
tout le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et dans quelques instants nous
reviendrons sur la crise du coronavirus
en france le ministère de la santé
annonce quatre cent soixante et onze
nouveaux décès ces dernières 24 heures à
l'hôpital
et puis ce sera les dites aux échos de
jacques sapir qui va tenter de répondre
à cette question
à la crise sanitaire risque-t-elle de
provoquer une nouvelle dépression restez
avec nous sur rt france
[Musique]
nous allons évoquer ici les sujets
stratégiques pour notre pays et sur ces
dossiers sensibles
je vais partager avec vous une
interprétation en france une quinzaine
de zones ont été sélectionnés dans les
années 90 par des militants dieu la
première erreur de notes administration
a été de croire que les terroristes
étaient des loups solitaires alors
qu'ils étaient la résultante de 15 ans
de travail de fond fait par les
analystes soyons clairs ils ont prêché
la guerre sainte et le problème c'est
qu'on les a trop longtemps laissé il ya
eu un espèce de déni de réalité et la
famille drame du bataclan pour qu'il y
ait enfin une reconnaissance générale de
la situation dans notre pays
la ministre de la justice madame
belloubet annonce la sortie en 2020 de
43 du à 10 140 avant fin 2022 sur les
531 incarcéré aujourd'hui
qui peut croire que la majeure partie
des individus mus par la haine de la
france est désormais libre ne sont pas
un défi pour la sécurité nationale
[Musique]
qu'est ce qui pousse tout simplement un
apnéiste à vouloir touchées les abymes
le but ultime c'est pas forcément de
gagner des médailles whitelaw podium m6
d'arriver à gérer ses émotions dans un
certaine oriente et c'est un univers qui
nous permet justement d'aller encore
plus loin dans cet état d'introspection
et de travail sur le corps et aussi sur
les plus on va être dans l'instant
présent
on va être capable de gérer ce qu'on en
a à faire est de concentrer sur ce que
l'on fait et a confiance et la capacité
à vivre l'instant présent à être
connectés que sur ce qui se passe sur
les sons sur le toucher sur le ressenti
et ça nous pousse dans les
retranchements à changer des choses dans
notre propre vie en dehors de l'année
savent ils créent des livres est ce
assez
c'était un peu votre vote secret votre
ambition secrète quand on est actrice à
un moment donné
il faut faire autre chose il faut
prendre la parole il faut dire que je et
comment mieux qu'en écrivant votre livre
raconte l'histoire donc de vania vassia
et de leur fille sonia by sonia c'est un
peu vous serez pu êtes vous je voulais
que ce soit très passionnant et je
voulais en même temps faire un examen
une espèce de bilan de ce que j'avais
vécu le passé c'est comme une boucle ça
peut aussi être un réservoir pour des
données d'avenir vous êtes un marqueur
de l'immigration heureux ce n'est que
par vous êtes à bien cette forme est
d'accord qu'est ce qui vous a sauvé
qu'est-ce qui bouta booster écoutez
c'est la curiosité c'est quand même si
ça la france c'est que c'est un tremplin
pour ceux qui veulent réussir
il y a une problématique d'augmentation
extrêmement importante de la demande en
eau depuis la révolution verte qui
reconduit à à cette autosuffisance
alimentaire de l'inde dans ces zones
climatiques aride il ya quasiment plus
d'eau en surface
on compte maintenant à peu près sur le
pays de l'ordre de 25 millions depuis
pomper ce qui est six fois plus que la
chine
cette image une femme qui porte un pot à
eau sur la tête et une image que l'on
voit partout
pour les femmes c'est une charge énorme
des petites filles peuvent pas aller à
l'école parce que doivent aider à cette
tâche par exemple donc ça accentue des
inégalités 85% de l'eau consommée
en inde les par l'agriculture c'est un
des premiers exportateurs de blé de riz
des peas qui consomment énormément d'eau
pour être produite à l'échelle mondiale
d'eau virtuelle c'est à dire l'eau qui
est contenu dans les produits qui sont
échangées l'inde est un des plus gros
exportateurs d'eau donc c'est un
paradoxe en soi
l'italien depuis le début de cette crise
en europe en tout cas fonctionne un peu
comme un laboratoire pour nous il faut
observer ce qui se passe là bas on va
nettement vers l'arrêt complet de
pratiquement du sport mondial
tous les clubs et tout les sports sont
pas affectés de la même façon les gros
résisteront beaucoup mieux que les
petits une fois qu'on aura des sportifs
humaine qui seront contaminés comme ça a
pu être le cas dans le cyclisme
les choses qu'on encore différent qu'est
ce qu'on fera quand on aura une équipe
qui sera atteinte
entièrement ou vinci se transmettent etc
au fil du temps si ça continue le sport
va dans le mur est-ce que c'est grave
non ce qui est grave c'est qu'il y ait
des morts c'était les gens contaminés
c'est qu'ils aient des économies qui
sont susceptibles de s'effondrer le
sport n'est que du sport
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et merci de nous
rejoindre en direct pour une demi heure
d'information il est 21h heure de paris
tout de suite les titres de l'actualité
de ce jeudi 2 avril 2020 en france le
ministère de la santé annonce quatre
cent soixante et onze nouveaux décès ces
dernières 24 heures portant le bilan à
plus de 4500 morts depuis le début de
l'épidémie il y aurait eu au moins huit
cents 84 décès dans les maisons de
retraite précise jérôme salomon la
collecte des chiffres est toujours en
cours très bien le directeur général de
la santé faisant état de grandes
inégalités dans le recueil entre régions
l économie mondiale sévèrement touchés
par l'épidémie de coronavirus après
l'europe c'est l'économie américaine la
première au monde qui inquiète
industrie et services à l'arrêt un
million d'emplois menacés et les
projections de récession les plus
alarmistes commencent à circuler
elle cette crise présenté comme la pire
depuis 1945
risque-t-elle de provoquer une nouvelle
dépression là c'est la question à
laquelle l'économiste jacques sapir
tentera de répondre dans sa chronique
est qu attend quelques minutes
[Musique]
en france on dénombre donc quatre cent
soixante et onze nouveaux décès ces
dernières 24 heures - qui hier avec 509
personnes décédées il ce qui porte le
nombre total de victimes du commis de 19
à 4500 trois personnes sur le territoire
à des chiffres donnés il y à quelques
minutes par le directeur général de la
santé elle jérôme salomon a également
annoncé la présence de 6399 personnes
dans les services de réanimation et la
france déplore 884 décès au sein des
ehpad
elle c'est la première fois que le
directeur général de la santé indique
que le nombre de morts dans les
établissements pour personnes âgées
il s'ajoute donc au nombre de personnes
décédées à l'hôpital
une infirmière en colère sophie ravi la
publier sur les réseaux sociaux une
vidéo dénonçant la gestion du système de
santé français par le gouvernement elle
reproche notamment le mépris cas le
président emmanuel macron envers les
personnels soignants regarder j'accuse
j'accuse le président de la république
de non assistance aux soignants en
danger de mort dans l'exercice de leurs
fonctions j'accuse le président de la
république d'envoyer son armée blanche
au combat à mains nues sans arme c'est à
dire sans masques ffp2 et autres
protections indispensables pour se
protéger pour se défendre et pour
soigner et pour parler du personnel
soignant en première ligne face à la
crise à nous sommes avec sophie
rainville l'infirmière libérale dans
l'infirmière libérale dans le gard que
nous venons d'entendre sophie rainville
merci d'être avec nous sur rt france
alors on vient de le voir à vous avez
décidé de vous livrer dans une vidéo
pourquoi ce choix pourquoi parce que
comme tous mes collègues soignants voilà
plusieurs semaines qu'on crie à l'aide
on crie au secours de toutes les façons
qui soit il y en a qui chantent
il y en a qui font des spectacles des
photos des textes et nous avons nous
avons des médecins
qui crient au secours à l'aide des
soignants des infirmières et nous avons
le triste décision de triste constat de
ne pas être entendu comme nous devrions
être entendu je pense je pense pour pour
bien comprendre est-ce que vous pouvez
nous raconter votre quotidien dans
quelles conditions vous travaillez
aujourd'hui alors dans quelle condition
donc moi comme je suis infirmière
libérale c'est vrai que pour l'instant
par rapport à mes collègues hospitaliers
c'est différent et moi je suis dans le
gard dans une petite ville de ville où
le comique 19 commencent à arriver
donc voilà donc pour l'instant auprès de
mes patients un mois et ceux de mon
collègue elle n'avons pas encore de cas
de kobe de 19 mais pour nous ça devient
un enfer de pourrir à la chasse aux
matériels
c'est un enfer parce que nous n'avons
pas de masque est fait et deux au camp
nous en avons x ont péri mais on
aimerait en avoir eu des non périmés
tant qu'à faire
nous n'avons pas de lunettes
nous n'avons pas de chars lente nous
n'avons pas des gants des surchaussures
il manque des solutions
hydro-alcooliques d'être desprès
désinfectant nous commençons à avoir ça
un petit peu au concours mais c'est
celle affaire de dons c'est à dire c'est
le maire de notre commune qui a racheté
des anciens masque périmés c'est les
dons d'entreprises qui nous donnent des
masques
voilà et c'est la chasse aux masques
donc c'est rationner nous avons 18
masques chirurgicaux
donc ce sont les tout petits masques
convoi blanc que nous avons ce sont des
masques cela nous devons l'échangé que
les quatre heures normalement vous
pensez bien qu'avec 18 masque pour la
semaine pour faire naître pilonné
soigner des patients
justement qu'est-ce qui m'a justement
qu'est ce qu'on vous dit sur ce matériel
est ce que vous avez des informations
sur une homme prochaine réception de
matériel vers des tournées qu'est-ce
qu'on vous répond
si vous voulez on dit toujours les
masques arrivent les masses qui arrive
donc mais simplement ch ça fait trois
semaines qu'on nous dit que ça arrive
donc là maintenant ça devient plus
qu'urgent en plus qu urgent il nous faut
ce matériel et une sauce matériel et je
vais dit pour l'instant ça a été une
organisation locale en réseau dead de
soutien et de solidarité qui s'est
surtout opérer ici dans les premiers
dans en ce moment c'est ça qui se passe
on
on a en a des masses parce que les
jambes et donne quoi voilà alors les
entre mon entend bien effectivement
depuis le début de cette crise sanitaire
les inquiétudes le quotidien difficile
des infirmières qui sont en hôpital
quels sont les autres problématiques
vous en tant qu'infirmière libérales
auxquelles vous êtes confrontés c'est ça
c'est justement ce manque de matériel ce
matériel qu'on doit quand il est là qu
on doit acheter parce que nous devons
payer nos gants nos solutions
hydro-alcooliques
nous devrons payer tout ça alors que bon
normalement on pense que ça devrait nous
être fournie quoi ou en tout cas ne pas
être aussi cher que ça voilà des c'est
toujours cette chasse à chasse aux
matériels donc on reçoit des textos des
copains des pharmacies 10 points soit
super on m'a donné mille masques venez
on va les repartir donc on court à
droite et à gauche chercher notre
matériel en place confinement c'est pas
non plus le but je pense c'est pas non
plus le but alors en tout en déplacement
dans l'hôpital militaire de campagne de
mulhouse c'était la semaine dernière le
chef de l'état emmanuel lacroix fait
plusieurs promesses d'investissements
pour le monde médical comment est ce que
vous avez reçu justement ses promesses
j'ai envie de dire on y croit à chaque
fois mais qui joueront en attente de ça
on est toujours en attente d'être
attendu il ya eu tellement de cris
d'allah mains de tous les professionnels
de la santé que on attend qu'ils jour
ces masques on l'attend pitch matériel
mais je veux dire on voit rien arriver
ou pas suffisamment ou pas suffisamment
vite ou au compte gouttes
c'est pas normal c'est pas normal nous
on bosse tous les jours tous les jours à
5 heures on se lève pour aller jamin
tournée et ouais elle et on a la boule
au ventre on va faire notre boulot où on
a besoin parce que et on va bosser sans
avoir de poilus nous protéger et
protéger nous soignons également et tous
les soigner et une fourre ce matériel
c'est un matériel de base de protection
de base auquel unsa fo droit merci sophy
ravid pour votre témoignage je rappelle
que vous êtes infirmière libérale dans
le gard merci à vous malgré l'épidémie
du coronavirus les plus démunis peuvent
continuer à bénéficier des aides
associative illustration à lyon avec le
secours populaire qui revoit son
organisation luis carballo avec mehdi
skis fils touché mais toujours mobilisés
malgré les mesures de confinement en
place depuis le 17 mars plusieurs
associations caritatives poursuivre leur
action sur le cas notamment du secours
populaire au siège de cette célèbre
structure beaucoup moins d'activité que
d'habitude mais les portes restent
ouvertes et ce depuis le début de la
crise car les bénévoles seniors évite
par sécurité de se déplacer fidèle au
poste une équipe reste en place pour
gérer les affaires les plus urgentes
donc là on est dans la boutique du
secours populaire actuellement en effet
remet évidemment puisque ont des mesures
de sécurité on n'a pas le droit de il ya
trop de gens qui travaillent en même
temps ici et en plus il ya
habituellement beaucoup de beaucoup de
familles qui viennent pour acheter des
produits
donc c'est un endroit qu'on peut pas
qu'on peut pas garder ouverts en ce
moment moins de volontaires moins de
bénéficiaires mais pas de pénurie
d'aliments l'aide continue à arriver
notamment de la part des restaurateurs
et des associations locales
contraints de fermer leurs portes à
cause du confinement mais les ressources
financières commencent à manquer les
responsables du secours populaire
s'inquiète et demande un engagement sans
faille des pouvoirs publics pour
continuer à offrir une aide digne de ce
nom
l'épidémie l'association a adapté ses
horaires pour limiter les concentrations
de personnes d'ordinaire ouvert de lundi
à vendredi
la structure est désormais opérationnel
7 jours sur 7 la plupart des opérations
sont focalisés sur l'aide alimentaire
la métropole lyonnaise vient d'accorder
une aide d'urgence de 40000 euros
aujourd'hui on arrive à continuer de
pouvoir répondre aux besoins d'urgence
on l'aide alimentaire c'est une aide
vitale on se doit d'essayer d'y répondre
au maximum
on y arrive avec nos moyens mais nos
moyens vont commencer à baisser et se
sont pas forcément les deux premières
semaines les plus difficiles c'est que
ça commence à s'installer
nos ressources financières sont arrêtés
donc il faut qu'on trouve des solutions
et puis qu'on est aussi le maximum
d'appui notamment des pouvoirs publics
pour arriver à continuer la structure
d'accueil aux mineurs isolés est
également opérationnel
dans la salle une vingtaine de jeunes
alors qu'ils sont 80 ans normal en plus
du soutien scolaire et des cours de
français ils bénéficient d'une aide
alimentaire continue d'un accueil
minimum pour les mineurs isolés
effectivement qui ne sont pas pris en
charge
puisque nous leur servons les repas
n'ont pas d'autres lieux pour manger
actuellement donc on prépare des sacs on
ordonne des sacs on leur donne les
fameuses attestations dû leur permettre
de se déplacer et tous les gens quand
ils viennent on leur donne en même temps
une liasse de feuilles des exercices à
faire pour se préparer leur future
scolarisation les valeurs de solidarité
reste bien présente malgré les
difficultés de fonctionnement liées à la
crise sanitaire
reste à savoir si ces acteurs
incontournables de la solidarité
pourront tenir dans la durée
notamment si les mesures de confinement
était amené à être prolongée l'économie
mondiale sévèrement touché par
l'épidémie et de coronavirus après
l'europe c'est l'économie américaine la
première au monde qui inquiète
en france l'insee a tenté de chiffrer
l'impact économique du confinement et il
s'annonce historiquement élevé cette
crise présenté comme la pire depuis 1945
risque-t-elle de provoquer une nouvelle
dépression eh bien on voit cela tout de
suite avec l'économiste jacques sapir
avec nous par skype confinement oblige à
bienvenue jacques
merci olivier alors jacques pourquoi de
nombreux économistes parle-t-il d'une du
risque d'une dépression aujourd'hui y
compris en france
mais olivier l'économie française est en
train de s'arrêter avec le confinement à
de nombreuses activités ne peuvent en
effet passé au télétravail et se faire
de manière décentralisée le risque d'une
faillite d'ailleurs se précise pour de
nombreuses pme et pas seulement nous
avons appris aujourd'hui que le
chausseur andré et s'était mis en
cessation de paiement et donc ce rite va
être d'autant plus grand que la durée du
confinement va s'allonger
alors comme vous l'avez dit l'insee a
publié les premières prévisions et ces
dernières ne sont pas bonnes elles sont
d'ailleurs très probablement encore trop
optimiste il faut donc s'attendre à ce
que le coronavirus pousse l'économie
française ainsi que d'autres économies
dans le monde dans la dépression alors
jacques est-ce que vous pouvez nous en
dire un petit peu plus un sur les
prévisions de l'insee
oui tout à fait alors l'insee a fait une
première estimation de la baisse
d'activité de l'économie
elle l'estimé car je rappelle que ces
chiffres datent maintenant du 26 mars et
l'estimé à moins de 35 % du niveau
global d'activité seulement
et c'est un vrai véritable problème
cette estimation est certainement trop
optimiste par exemple sur l'agriculture
où il ya une baisse que de 4% et bien on
va constater très vite que l'agriculture
manque de main d'oeuvre saisonnière même
chose des services marchands et non
marchands
même quand le télétravail peut être
utilisés connaissent en réalité des
baisses de production plus importante
que les chiffres qui sont estimés par
l'insee alors du coup jacques calais
vous votre estimation
avec quelques collègues nous avons fait
nos estimations en utilisant d'ailleurs
les les données de l'insee
nous avons calculé la production
hebdomadaire de l'économie française
puis nous avons calculé cela en fonction
de l'impact du confinement
comme vous pouvez le voir la première
colonne donne le niveau de production
hebdomadaire pour 2019
la seconde pourcentage estimé de baisse
de la production est roi coach on a été
peut-être plus sévère que l'insee et la
troisième la valeur hebdomadaire de la
production une fois la fin du conte
filmant et comment cela serait partie
t-il en fonction du nombre de semaines
de confinement est bien regardons tout
d'abord ce que nous dit l'insee alors
lindsay n'a pas calculé par semaine mais
a calculé par mois et on voit ici que
pour un mois la baisse globale sur
l'année 2020 serait de 3% la baisse
globale pour deux mois serait 2 6%
ce sont les chiffres qui sont donnés par
l'insee mais sur ce point vous vous
diverger aussi jacques oui parce que
nous avons considéré que le confinement
duré tout d'abord entre 6 et 8 semaines
et nous allons surtout considéré que le
retour à la normale ne seraient pas
automatiques ainsi que le suppose
l'insee nous avons mangé avec lui dans
nous donner ces différents aspects et
nous l'avons fait y compris pour les
données de l'insee
alors on voit là que ça pousse les
données de l'insee à 8% pour huit
semaines mais que donne aux données nous
arrivons à -10%
nous avons aussi une troisième hypothèse
qui combine un petit peu l'hypothèse de
l'insee est la nôtre et qui suppose par
exemple que dans les deux premières
semaines
eh bien on pourrait avoir des niveaux de
production qui serait proche de ce que
l'insee
après
mais qu'après pour la 3e 4e 5e semaine
et bien l'économie se calmer
progressivement sur notre scénario et on
voit là que l'on arrive à une baisse de
production pour l'année 2020 je le
répète 29.7 pour ça mais du coup jacques
ce sont des baisses considérables
oui absolument olivier sont des baisses
tout à fait considérable le choc sur la
production et le pire que la france ait
connue depuis la seconde guerre mondiale
depuis 1945
l'impact sur les pme peut être
absolument dévastateur les grandes
entreprises sont elles mieux protégés
par le système de chômage partiel qui
touche désormais quatre millions de
personnes
mais si le gouvernement tarde à soutenir
les pme et les tpe qui n'ont plus de
rentrées d'argent il faut le dire
eh bien nous pourrions avoir entre eux
ça cent mille et un million de chômeurs
de plus à la fin de cette année et quel
en sera l'impact sur les finances
publiques solides il faut bien dire que
l'impact sera lourd est là aussi nous
avons utilisé les chiffres de l'été puis
nous avons utilisé nos propres
estimations et on voit que le fardeau ça
pourrait être un déficit budgétaire
allant de - 8 % pour le calcul de six
semaines de l'insee jusqu à -11% pour
huit semaines
d'après les calculs que nous avons fait
alors que peut-il se passer
et bien bonne question
on a plusieurs en a plusieurs
hypothèques ce alors trois sources de
financement ont été évoqués tout d'abord
les fameux corona bon les bons qui
seraient émis uniquement 1 par rapport à
cette épidémie et dont on sait qu'ils
ont été refusé d'emblée par l'allemagne
et par les pays bas et puis nous avons
la mobilisation du mécanisme européen de
stabilité mes là les italiens et les
français d'ailleurs exige qu'il se fasse
sans condition ceux qui refusaient par
l'allemagne donc exit aussi cette
possibilité reste ce qu'a fait la banque
centrale européenne ce qu'on appelle le
pandémique emma jones épaule chasing
programme
et qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce qui va
en résulter et bien tout simplement que
la banque centrale européenne va se
mettre à acheter massivement de la dette
des différents pays de la zone rouge
alors on est aujourd'hui devant une
situation qui devient de plus en plus
compliqué vous voyez que le confinement
plus il durera plus il provoquera une
dépression sévère de l'économie et on
voit aussi que de la politique du
gouvernement de sa capacité à réagir
dépendra énormément le fait que cette
dépression ne soit que transitoire ce
qu'il faut espérer ou qu'elles se
prolongent
malheureusement au delà de l'épidémie
merci beaucoup jacques pour ses
explications très éclairant 20 sur les
implications économiques de cette crise
sans précédent bon courage dans votre
confinement à très bientôt sur rt france
merci à vous olivier cette crise
sanitaire a contraint les états
européens à adopter des mesures
d'urgence parmi elles la surveillance de
masse drones données de géolocalisation
certains s'inquiètent en vertu de la
sécurité les libertés individuelles
pourraient être mises à mal le débat est
ouvert regarder
[Musique]
en israël benyamin nétanyahou a annoncé
le confinement de la ville de bné brak
dans la banlieue de tel aviv où le taux
de contes animations au coronavirus est
le plus élevé du pays
dans la seule nuit de mardi à mercredi
le nombre de cas répertoriés a augmenté
de plus de 25% au total 600 soldats sont
actuellement mobilisées pour aider la
police à faire respecter les mesures de
confinement dans le pays enfin deux
millions de doses diderot xi chloroquine
vont être offertes par le géant
pharmaceutique teva au ministère
israélien de la santé à la livraison est
prévue d'ici dix jours pour aider à
traiter des patients atteints du
coronavirus les précisions sur la
situation en israël avec pierre et offre
des journalistes réalisateurs et auteurs
de tête de veau édition mécanique
générale il compare avec la situation de
bibracte dans la banlieue de tel-aviv
le taux de contamination est d'environ
34% alors qu'était la vie par exemple je
réside le taux de contamination par
rapport évidemment au nombre de gens
testé pour l'instant et deux ans
l'auteur de 5 6% ce qui démontre quand
même que lorsque les consignes sont
respectées
on arrive à plus ou moins au niveau
gouvernemental à contrôler la situation
aujourd'hui dans l'ensemble d'israël
nous avons 6300 pipoles de 6300
personnes qui ont été excusés moi tout
mais d'autres sont en anglais qui on est
et qui sont considérés comme atteinte du
corona et nous avons malheureusement à
ce jour plus de trente nord et
évidemment les chiffres sont en
augmentation permanente puisque nous
assistons à une contamination qui est
exponentielle je pense que le pic va
être atteint aux alentours du 15 avril
et je pense qu'à ce moment là on aura
quelques milliers de morts et ça c'est
actuellement épouvantable mais bon c'est
une réalité mais pour convaincre le
coronavirus nous
rhdp y trouve des solutions moins
conventionnelles ont fait le point en
images
[Rires]
face à cette situation d'urgence
sanitaire nationale nous avons compris
l'intérêt de faire fabriquer ses
costumes qui implique de se déplacer
pour éduquer les citoyens avec
créativité
des policiers interviennent avec les
mêmes costumes à cochabamba et plus
encore ici à la paz où nous avons mis
l'accent sur la nécessité de veiller à
ce que les citoyens ne soient pas
présents sur la voie publique les agents
en costume vont et viennent afin de les
en empêcher
[Rires]
[Musique]
bienvenue à aider cam marc stocker je
m'appelle peppers et même en temps de
crise nous voulons vous soutenir par un
bon service en raison de l'épidémie de
corona je voudrais vous rappeler de
prendre certaines précautions dans notre
supermarché
veuillez garder une distance de sécurité
d'environ 2 m la deuxième zone est conçu
pour que vous puissiez faire vos courses
sur le tapis roulant en toute
tranquillité
la troisième est destiné à vous
permettre d'en bas les vos achats
[Rires]
nous
[Musique]
et dans le monde entier les mesures de
protection contre le virus sont en place
je vous propose un tour d'horizon en
images
[Musique]
non
et c'est la fin de cette émission un peu
écourtée en raison du coronavirus et
comme tous les médias nous sommes
contraints de réduire nos programmes
prochain point complet sur l'actualité
ce sera demain à 9 heures mon courage à
tous et très bonne soirée sur arte
france
[Musique]
il
c'est le sentiment que vous avez eue
vous aussi ce besoin d'autonomie
oui complètement vrai besoin d'autonomie
besoin de retourner à des choses plus
essentielles en fait est vraiment de
sentir qu'on n'est pas forcément un
poids pour la planète
il ya une idée derrière il ya une
philosophie aussi qu'on a vu la serre
les plantes qui poussent le fait de
vivre avec les plantes comme ça vraiment
commune comme une machine un organisme
pour fait partie de cet organisme
on a eu vraiment l'impression de se
construire en même temps qu'on vous
construisez cette maison en faisant
toutes ces rencontres mais je pense que
ces gens de projets qui se fait pas tout
seul dans son coin on est dans un truc
vraiment de coopération de partage de
partage
[Musique]
si vous fermez les bourses nous empêcher
les gens de vendre et donc vous les
condamnez à une poursuite de la baisse
qui veut dire qu'on va être dans une
récession monumentale mais est ce qu'on
peut imaginer que les épargnants puisse
être inquiétés et ont des raisons d'être
inquiète à cause de cette fille oui bien
sûr que vous avez aujourd'hui un risque
majeur qu'on ne vous rend pas d'autres
cas c'est une évidence
à aucun moment dans l'histoire récente
vous n'avez eu des pays à l'arrêt jamais
à l'échelle européenne quelles peuvent
être ses réponses